savoir-faire lien social emplois locaux
et développement durable
samedi 13 octobre dernier pour la
quatrième édition de la journée
nationale du commerce de proximité de
l'artisanat et des centres villes les
commerçants d'elancourt ont mis en avant
leurs atouts et en ont profité pour
proposer de nouvelles prestations
ce soir on fait une soirée vaines
donc il ya des massages le salon sera
décoré de bougies
avec de la musique de yoga donc c'est un
autre aspect de la passion dans ce salon
les habitués semblent attachés à la
proximité quirinal et disponibilité sont
embêterait de devoir aller plus loin
parce que là j'ai juste ça monte à pied
c'est vrai que c'est pratique
que ce soit pour aller à la poste ou au
supermarché je suis bien ici d'avoir
tous les commerces à disposition à côté
de chez soi ou à côté du travail c'est
quand même c'est primordial à mon avis
plutôt que ceux des de devoir se
déplacer à des kilomètres prendre sa
voiture
oui c'est très important louis le
mauvais temps ne sera pas parvenue à
freiner la synergie entre les
commerçants près d'une trentaine d'entre
eux ont participé à l'opération cette
année au fur et à mesure nos plus en
plus de commerçants qui participent donc
c'est quand même nettement mieux pour
nous parce qu'effectivement c'est vrai
une vraie cohérence aux commerçants
prochain rendez vous le 1er décembre
pour le marché de noël